this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash app do you
want to get paid five dollars and also
give five dollars to charity or are you
awful do you want to buy and sell
Bitcoin instantly or get your paycheck
deposited directly into the app of
course you do
all the babies use the cash app which is
why I'm probably why honestly it shot up
to the number one finance app in the App
Store it's really great you guys got to
download it download the free cash app
for iOS or Android now this episode is
also brought to you by blue apron blue
apron is offering our listeners $30 off
your first delivery when it comes to
dinner let blue apron take care of the
planning and shopping while you do all
the cooking and the eating and it's good
for your families you'll enjoy delicious
meals like popcorn chicken with sweet
chili cabbage slaw and other really
delicious stuff I eat it a lot and its
really really great check out this
week's menu and get your $30 off with
free shipping at blue apron calm /
Congrats blue apron a better way to cook
[Laughter]
[Music]
what's up my babies we're here at that
congratulations studios and with I'm
with one fire and I even get rid of and
we're chillin
we are chillin it is episode 62 who the
[ __ ] knew we could do it but you know
what we did it and the Internet's not
working now 1 fire because he is in
charge of that didn't it's not working
so we don't have our screen up which is
fine but we are live on the app right
now and I'm looking at you guys right
now I'm looking at your comments and
we're gonna do the first 10 minutes here
live on the app [ __ ] it we'll do it live
and now don't hold TV is completely
offset one fire and it's all good but
it's that's how it is
hey did you guys so download the app and
you can join the first ten minutes of
the podcast live every now and then
we're gonna do be doing that to keep the
babies have a nice communal place I see
your comments and you guys are great
some of you guys may be killers though
so who knows some of you guys may be
killed one or two people as we've talked
about before now so I was I took a
flight every single day this [ __ ]
week and I'm jet lagged as [ __ ] I got
home on Sunday night I had falsely about
10:00 p.m. I haven't done that since I
was 11 years old and I also haven't done
that since I had the flu so and then
also I had then the next night which was
last night I fell asleep at 11:00 so
very cool very cool man
so cool how grandpa I don't even have
kids I don't even have kids
and those kids don't even have kids but
I'm going to sleep like grandpa so it
was April force now did you participate
in April Fool's you did you boring
bottom line if you do it poor fools
you're boring because just that's it's
an excuse April Fool's is an excuse for
people with no personality to all of a
sudden seem like they have personality
just because a day makes you do some fun
[ __ ] what you do tell somebody you were
pregnant ah by the way that's not even
funny who thinks it's funny to prank
someone that's what I want to know it's
so not funny to prank someone did I'm
looking jacked in my app livestream what
the [ __ ] oh [ __ ] is going on dude move
over Chris Hemsworth but yeah you're
boring as [ __ ] if you do if you do April
Fool's
who the [ __ ] thinks it's funny to prank
someone I'm pregnant really no oh okay
oh yeah gotcha oh yeah yeah oh cool now
what we just go around and do our
regular day let's eat a sandwich and go
shopping [ __ ] out of here whoever
we would talk about this on the set of
undateable me and Ron Funches totally
agreed that pranks are for [ __ ]
people who are not funny yeah
let's just say this people who
constantly do pranks if you do a prank
or - fine but people who like are
pranksters oh those people dude those
people grind my gears oh you know him
he's a prankster
oh really what'd he do like someone
shoes on fire I'll cool hey really
you're just a [ __ ] dick I knew a guy
that was like would like light guys
shoes on fire hey you dick
they're really well I I've a Maasai
can't say it if I say it then he'll
[ __ ] if I was gonna one fire was like
who and I he knows who but I can't I'll
tell him after the podcast nobody will
know i was in tallahassee on wednesday
did a show there and i got so many it's
what was interesting about tallahassee
is that was like afterwards i got so
many followers like the and all the
followers are we're getting were like
hot girls that had like 3,000 followers
on Instagram a say FSU dude if you're a
college girl how do you not at least
have a few thousand followers on
Instagram there's so many creeps out
there you know there's so many [ __ ]
fat-bellied thin haired guys in like
Wichita that why will the [ __ ] wouldn't
they follow this this young 20 year old
thing that's like a [ __ ] fig biochem
major that's gonna never do anything
with it a reality but why the [ __ ] dude
why the [ __ ] wouldn't like why the [ __ ]
wouldn't you have I don't get it if you
I always would said like if you're a
chicken you don't have to twenty
thousand followers on Instagram the [ __ ]
you done makes no sense makes zero sense
it's it is cool but yeah but somebody
April Fool's is just it's just horrible
but I was in let's see so I went to
Tallahassee that was a great show
enjoy doing that a lot of the people
came out it wasn't just for the students
it was for people to to sell it they
sold tickets and then I went to
University of Miami which was okay
the students were great they were loving
it the venue was kind of janky for
comedy and then I went to Orlando which
was awesome do it
Orlando's crazy it's all families and
[ __ ] because it just was like a town
built for like theme park
it's like theme park [ __ ] and I did a
show there and it was awesome man
I put it on my Instagram everyone was so
cool on the show and then I did South
Carolina I did Charleston South Carolina
I did two shows there Charleston
Charleston South Carolina is great and I
got a I had a heckler that I had to
throw out and he and I found out
afterwards he didn't have sleeves on
dude if you're a heckler don't also have
a sleeveless shirt huh you're just gonna
be the Biggest Loser of all time you're
gonna be the Biggest Loser of all time
not wearing sleeves and then the second
show in South Carolina I swear to god
this guy had a sleeveless shirt on and
it said I'm not bullshitting you in the
front row his shirt said I'm not making
this up
[ __ ] sleeves get a job imagine you had a
shirt on that had no sleeves that said
[ __ ] sleeves that you know what respect
to that [ __ ] for real but when I
was after the show and the in the after
the show in what do you call it South
Carolina I walked down Charleston the
street in Charleston and I saw two girls
get in a fight and she kicked in a door
at this [ __ ] pizza place and it broke
and it splintered and then she ran away
and then she was like his racist she was
like you're being racist and she wasn't
because really she kicked in the door
and that's why they threw her out she's
like why didn't you kick out her as you
point to a white girl and two white
girls just stand-in there
a key she didn't kick in the door and
then I walked in and I was like I don't
know if I want to go in it was crazy and
then and then and then we did and then I
got it got pizza so worst story of all
time and then I got pizza dude that's
how every story should end and then I
got pizza so and then I and then that's
it that's it just I wanted to talk about
how the [ __ ] and I saw a fight by the
way what's up with you know what the
worst thing to do at when people when
there's like a street fight is when I
see people on snapchat just like this
and people are beating the [ __ ] out of
each other and they're just like you
[ __ ] [ __ ] you don't have to
actually try and break up the fight but
don't document it for your nine
followers you piece of [ __ ] leave at
least leave or at least don't document
it hey all of a sudden are you [ __ ]
Verner Hertzog
is that the guy hey all of a sudden are
you Verner Hertzog also it's Werner said
German here we see all of the people
fighting at the pizza place I mean
people are snapchatting and we are
documenting it to see who will win is
this race baited thing it says black
woman fighting the door and she is
claiming it as race they are throwing
her out right now and she is claiming it
is because she's black but actuality it
just maybe because she kicked in the
door and it splinted out and you cannot
have broken window you cannot have
broken window at a pizza place
yeah and dudes were just like and it's
always God those guys look like such
[ __ ] one time I saw a guy [ __ ]
videoing something with his iPad like
that dude that's what I want to be I
want to be the guy at the concert you
know how the guys used to put up the
lighters and then they used to put up
the [ __ ] and now they put up the
cellphones I want to have the guy with a
[ __ ] with an iPad that's like [ __ ]
what will be the song before you do it
some John Mayer [ __ ] mother's become
daughters and daughters become mothers
and brothers become fathers been nice to
y'all daughters whatever that sort is
guys come in ladies and ladies have a
ladies and those ladies get coming in
after they become old enough and then
there was people come mothers that's
that's that's how I wanna that said
that's the song I want to do with just
[ __ ] a guitar ladies become ladies and
women become women anyway I'm having I'm
having I just turned off the I turned
off the the live stream because somebody
tried to call me in the middle of it and
the sound went off that's why that
happened everybody we could play my
buddy Brett Davis [ __ ] him for calling I
literally just saw him at the coffee
shop don't call me dude who calls anyone
nowadays see ya
the [ __ ] just saw him by the way just so
my buddy Brett Davis he played I was in
XOXO and i just saw his he played a guy
who was like trying to beat me up and
dude he was wearing Jean jeans okay a
grey shirt hoodie and a jean jacket and
it's [ __ ] 70 something degrees in LA
and he was like hey bro I was like well
you looking white he dressed like this
right now by the way look at this guy
this guy's the [ __ ] man ah he's like
six five super attractive is that one of
those
you look at him he's a guy and then also
like you look at other dorks and you're
like oh that's a guy two different
species anyway this guy it was like I
was like why are you dressed in all this
[ __ ] he was like I'm a just woke up took
a shower I feel good and I looked and he
had [ __ ] chocolate all over his shirt
thank you to be that good-looking and
dope and tall and fit and then to have
chocolate stains on you that's like the
biggest [ __ ] you to a beta you know I'll
give a [ __ ] so yeah don't snapchat
[ __ ] fights also you're a you're bad
at it
you know you ever see people shoot
fights and you ever see them on like
Instagram and [ __ ] you're just like oh
come on if they're not getting it right
shoot everything widen it out
[ __ ] widen it out it's amazing
it's astonishing how bad people are
taking pictures actually it's
astonishing dude get everything in the
[ __ ] frame when you ask somebody a
can you take a picture of me and and and
whoever my lovely wife or my lovely
[ __ ] kids and then they're like okay
and they take a picture and like the
feet are out of it Hey are you [ __ ]
insane get the feet in it get the feet
in it get the head in it and get above
the head in it is it that is it that
[ __ ] hard get all the [ __ ] body
parts in it and then also get the things
above the body parts get the things
above the head if there's a [ __ ]
poster make sure the whole posters in it
if it's in front of a church make sure
the top of the church is in it what do I
just want half the [ __ ] church why do
you think I'm taking a picture of it I
might as well just take a picture of me
in front of the [ __ ] wall
la-da-da get the [ __ ] church and it
get the crossing at one time I saw a
picture of a church somebody in front of
a church on Instagram and the top of the
church was cut off and the cross was cut
off on top of the church it going tell
you know what you go in town and I'll
tell you what if I was Jesus Christ or
if I was the guy who ever it is Nicolas
Cage up there whoever the [ __ ] it is
you're going to hell you're going to
hell for cropping that here's the deal
you're going to hell for taking the pic
and I'm gonna find out because I'm the
holy
and I know it all if you're Jesus Christ
I will find out if it's the guy who took
the pictures fault or if the person
cropped it out to put it on Instagram oh
[ __ ] not only you're going to hell
you're going to [ __ ] deep hell you
going to [ __ ] deep hell you ever been
deep house bro you ever gonna [ __ ]
deep hell that's where [ __ ] it's hell
and then also they play the darkest hour
on a loop the most British movie of all
time even though it's not British well
it is kind of British actually heard
some things dude my opener blew my
[ __ ] mind
he blew my mind this past trip now let
me tell you something dude this is what
he [ __ ] told me we were talking I was
with him and another buddy of ours he
traveled with us we're having a good
time on the road doing whatever we were
talking about porn I don't know why we
started talking about porn I don't
remember and I don't even remember what
the beginning of the conversation was
like I want to say it was us talking
about like what kind of porn we like but
I don't think we were actually talking
about that but it led to the discussion
going into a place where my opener said
yeah I don't really watch porn but when
I do I go on to the porn site and I just
click whatever video I see
dude he clicks the first video uh
come on dude hey have preference who
clicks on the first naked bodies you see
look at what you want to click on dude
you know what that means and I told him
this and he gets so pissed off but I
told him this and it's the [ __ ] truth
if you go out because I know he's not
doing one that does this obviously you
still sit down and then [ __ ] click ah
porn yay oh there's one there's a girl
if you do that if you don't click at
least you don't have to click category
you don't have to go and be like ooh
you know [ __ ] or like threesome or my
favorite is my favorite is babes then
those [ __ ] they're all babes but the
category is babes
you know that's assuming that the other
categories don't have babes in them
who's giving [ __ ] in the blow job
category [ __ ] trolls who's given the
blow jobs in the blow jobs babes so put
that in the babes adieu every video
should be under babes what do you got in
the [ __ ] threesomes what's the
threesome with a guy and two [ __ ]
Neanderthals he's just a guy [ __ ] a
cardboard box and there and and and and
then he [ __ ] a hat that's the threesome
but wait what was I saying oh yeah so
you don't have to click category but you
at least have to like search a little
bit now I got to be honest I got to be
completely honest I don't really watch
that much porn I really don't so I'm not
into it that much I don't know that much
about porn but when I do I mean every
guys watched it when I've watched it I
sift around
you gotta sift around you don't just
click on [ __ ] first brunette you see
that's what he said he did and I told
him this and I'm sure of this and I'm no
scientist but I am now when it comes
down to it if you click on the first
porn you see to [ __ ] get the job done
as they say which I don't like when
people say [ __ ] like that here's the
here's the Depp here is something that's
100% true you're bad at
sex you're bad at sex and I told him
this I said that's how I know I always
said he was bad at sex but I was like
that's how I know you're bad at sex
because you don't have preference if you
don't have preference sexually and
you're just like an whatever then you're
just trying to [ __ ] have sex the way
that it you know is just easiest or
whatever now here's the other thing to
you as a guy you gotta have a mixture if
you have in sex you can't have sex to
please the girl dude you cannot have sex
to please the girl that's not you gotta
have you gotta you gotta please the girl
but also you have to have a mixture of
pleasing the girl and also doing it the
way you want to do it having a
preference if you have sex all to please
a girl then you congratulations are bad
at sex and you're a beta because what
girls want is a guy that knows what he
wants
see ya you don't know what you want if
you're trying to please someone else ya
see ya
you got to take what you want in a non
rapey way that's what sex is it's
domination delenn-- then then then vote
for me sex is domination don't rape but
also know what you want and don't try to
please a girl dental in then and any
[ __ ] buddy that tells you different
is bad at sex or less good at sex than
someone who knows how to do that or they
are congratulations a beta or whatever
the C is alpha beta whatever the CIS
that's what you are what is it charlie
oh all of a sudden it's a name
alpha beta Charles no but not in the
Greek letters yeah I [ __ ] this guy
would you go to Nam [ __ ] him dude one
fire there is no C but there's a de and
gamma and [ __ ] there's no C with the
Greeks they don't [ __ ] they're like we
don't need to cease
yeah we'll go right to D we'll go right
to the Dill's neck dude I'm telling you
man if you click on the first porn guess
what you're bad at sex at least [ __ ]
try when you're looking at porn try
nevermind I was talking about doing
their mature alors remember that [ __ ]
that is the most funny [ __ ] porn dude
the guy's talking to the girl say
clinical oh wow there we go
when yet when when when they're having
sex oh wow well isn't that nice
wow he only takes his dick out of the
pit at pants and then zips it back up
and buckles he unzips it takes his [ __ ]
and balls out and then buckles his pants
back so only his dick and balls are it
takes so much work so weird and awesome
[ __ ] man
oh my god I'm on the war on the amateur
lore website and the tagline is where
nice girls come to swallow come in the
world we live in
rabbits reviews 2016 a rise Awards
winner absolutely nothing man I mean you
know it's kind of weird
now one fire is looking at [ __ ] like
thumbnails of like [ __ ] and there's
just three dudes in this small podcast
room anyway I couldn't believe he blew
my mind when he said that I just click
on the first poll like what bro do you
have a brain what do you [ __ ] like
that's just so a guy that is like 9 to 5
has a family duh is not very sexual but
like thinks like you know what I'll just
I'll just do it because I know it'll end
up feeling good you know have you ever
have you ever done that I've never done
that like oh dude
I'm not into it but I know it'll feel
good if I do it
that's probably means you have a problem
I don't know oh let's do ads here yeah
okay
guys me undies you've heard me talk
about me undies and you know I'm a big
believer in their product and I'll tell
you what - there really are the perfect
balance of comfortable fit every month
they have a new and exciting prints that
arrive at your door and if I'm back now
let me tell you about this okay the
other day I put on underwear that
weren't me undies because my mom got me
them for Christmas and I just threw them
on I will never do that again these
underwear and if you don't know them if
you don't have them if you never tried
them you don't know what I'm talking
about but I'm being very dramatic
because it's the truth
these are the best most comfortable
underwear you will ever own period I'm
telling you as Chris D'Elia not the guy
who is because this is an ad they use
this micro modal in their underwear
lensing micro moto
it's sustainably sourced naturally soft
fiber that starts with beech wood trees
and ends with the most amazing fabric
you ever experienced I don't know but
it's amazing okay my undies has a great
offer for my listeners for any
first-time purchasers when you purchase
any me undies you get 20% off and free
shipping the undies is so sure you'll
love their underwear they offer a 100%
satisfaction guarantee if you don't love
your first pair you get a full refund
this is a no-brainer
you get 20% off a pair of the most
comfortable on these you will ever put
on to get your 20% off your first pair
free shipping a 100% satisfaction
guarantee go to me on DS dot-com slash
Congrats that's me Andy's comm /
Congrats guys I ate blue apron last
night and blue apron is really good I I
have yet to have a bad meal in blue
apron
it delivers fresh pre-portioned
ingredients and step-by-step recipes
right to your door that can be cooked in
under 45 minutes the menu changes every
week based on what's in season and is
designed by blue aprons in health
in-house culinary team it's great man
it's really good they've got the they
offer three meal plans the two-person
meal plan meals that serve two people
eight new recipes per week with trace of
to receive either two or three recipes
week family meal plan and they also have
a wine plan which is six bottles of wine
from renowned wine makers delivered
monthly I love blue apron the last thing
I had I think was it was this salmon
with like kale and like fennel in it and
it was really good and I also make made
the this chicken with I can't remember
but it was so good it had like this
salsa verde on it anyway the upcoming
meals tiger washy popcorn chicken seared
salmon and lemon labna I don't know what
that is
see it steaks cumin spice wonton noodles
with vegetable and peanuts look check
out this week's menu and get your $30
off with free shipping at blue apron
dot-com / Congrats blue apron a better
way to cook do the next one
Square cash if you haven't heard we've
switched to the cash app if you haven't
heard you don't listen to the podcast
the podcast boasts that this cash app is
the simplest way to pay people back
friends family
babies elders you can pay anyone back
with it sending and receiving money is
totally free and fast and most payments
can be deposited directly into your bank
account in just a few seconds
and did you know that the cash app lets
you do way more than that now you can
even buy and sell Bitcoin instantly do
do you want to be hip do you want to be
in the know then do it with Bitcoin get
your paycheck deposited directly into
the app pull money out of the ATM with
free with your free custom cash card
which I've talked about on previous
episodes or use it to spend anywhere you
like you really won't find a more useful
finance app out there I'm telling you
design your cards and tweet us a pic we
want to see it I want to see it some
people draw kudos on it with a no khuda'
thing on it or some people announce that
their babies on their card it's very
cool
and of course when you download the cash
app five dollars goes to you and five
dollars goes to the times up Legal
Defense Fund so guys be good purse
download it download the free cash app
for iOS or Android now yeah so
that's speaking of porn
how much as a guy I was I had that I was
having this conversation as a guy a
straight guy how much I want to know I
wanna I want honest answers and I want
you to tweet me how much would you get
paid to get [ __ ] in the ass because I
and I want a real number I want you to
tweet me a real number because I think
and I mean this I wouldn't do it for any
amount of money and let me tell you why
I offered me ten million dollars I don't
think I would do it now
of course you can't say oh you don't
know if somebody was really there with
ten million dollars cash you got to be
like all right it's different now
because it's real but here's why I think
I wouldn't do it
because I live the exact life I want to
live I make enough money where I can do
what I want to do if I had ten extra
million dollars
I guess what what would be different I
would what would I do I wouldn't travel
more I travel all the time uh I maybe
buy another house that I would barely go
to because I love being in LA you know a
hundred million dollars I guess I would
fly private that would be the only big
difference is that worth getting look I
think I look I don't want to get porked
in the butt right so that would be with
me I would think about it every single
day and it would like [ __ ] me up but I
want to know how much it would cost if
there's a number so tweet me that
because I was with guys and somebody
said they would do it for somebody was
like you wouldn't do for a hundred
thousand dollars and I was like hey man
no you know cuz it's not like sex it's
not like saying like if you're not a
game
that's something you don't want to have
happen right there's another guy put in
your butt so that's like a real mental
thing you'd have to overcome and also
it's not like it's not like a girl being
a hooker being like yeah okay I have sex
with me dude because or maybe it is a
little like that but I mean it's a
little like that but it's like as a guy
that takes away your masculinity it
takes away its his some in in their head
it takes away so much it would it would
be like a lot of guys huh I guess I
guess maybe if somebody was like had
knew their family would be safe if they
made a lot of money doing it then they
would maybe do it then I understand that
and because then they would be like I'll
just live with it everyday but like my
family will be set I don't know actually
regret even bringing this up on the
podcast but whatever that's how we do it
sometimes we get into some dark
territory and that's it one fire right
now is like 15 grand he's like an Ivan
get rid of his like I would do it for 25
he's thinking he just goes like this to
me he goes like this he goes like that
he might even met $15 I have no [ __ ]
idea
a lot of sexual [ __ ] on today's podcast
I guess I'm sorry I mean I'm not sorry
but I also have a theory and I wrote
this down because I want to talk about
this some if the more a girl changes her
name the more likely she the more sexual
partner she has that's my theory like if
you know our Facebook could be on
Facebook and somebody's name is like a
[ __ ] Yves Smith and then it's like
[ __ ] she changes it to like Brooke
Eve and you're like is that your first
name of your [ __ ] second name that
girl has sex with more guys than a girl
who never changes her name I knew a girl
once that was a
I met her and she was like yeah I'm this
name and then I was I got cool and I put
my her name on my phone and they would
text back and forth and then fell out of
touch and then ran into her again and
she was like and I called her the name
and she was like all my name is this now
and I was like oh really you just
changed it and she was like yeah I
didn't like it I was like okay and then
I ran into her again and I was calling
and I was calling her the first name and
I was like all sorry I know you change
your name she's like no I changed it
back who thinks that they're that
important who who thinks that that that
they're that important that they're like
you change your name once all right fine
you change your name twice who cares
just leave it the second time you [ __ ]
up you know Oh guys Chris oh you know
what imma change it to Derick yeah you
know what boom back to Crete how [ __ ]
annoying and embarrassing is that by the
way to go back to the first name oh by
the way everybody I go by Chris again
now that Derrick thing was a phase by
the way she was like 26 to old for it
yeah now I was like look this is the
last time I'm changing your [ __ ] name
in my phone this is what its gonna be
for now this is who you are all right to
me this is really [ __ ] are you know
I'm gonna do something so disrespectful
to you guys I'm gonna order [ __ ] post
mates while I'm here you guys want me to
order you something
no what one fire and Ivan get rid of
done give a [ __ ] oh dude I mean dude I
ordered sushi the other day on post
mates and I [ __ ] I cannot believe I
did this
I doubled the order by mistake it cost
me so much money dude it cost me I don't
want to say it
it was sushi I just looked at it it was
like you want to give the guy a 10% tip
would have been $4,000 I'm like I let me
do my own tip yeah
awful so disrespectful disorder some
food on your ass so disrespectful to
have a podcast and order food while
you're on the podcast and know that you
guys know I'm doing it and you're still
listening waiting for me to bring up the
next [ __ ] subject disrespectful but
dude sometimes you gotta wait in life
right sometimes you got to wait I don't
know I don't know I don't have any
[ __ ] I don't have it's what it is
it's [ __ ] April and it's already
April in 2018 how about people who say
that all the time oh it's [ __ ] it
dude can you believe it's April yeah the
months go as they [ __ ] go it's 30
days 30 days it's 30 days every single
month pretty much I can't believe he's
male ready really what have you been
doing just oh wait like what are you
having that much fun that's what you're
doing you're all you're doing is [ __ ]
eating starburst and common all you're
doing is eating starburst and [ __ ]
and [ __ ] and jerking off and going on
rollercoasters is that what you're doing
or no I did I I can't believe he's
[ __ ] me already I just been basically
all I've been doing really having sex
with models in eating starburst okay if
you're having sex with models everyday
and you're eating starburst if you're
Diplo you can say you know what I can't
believe it's May already but if you're
just some guy yeah it's [ __ ] May this
[ __ ] is so real
this [ __ ] is real as [ __ ] you and it
takes them to
questions or what um oh dude I never
know what it is because people always
tell me it's something different
Cameron Warren worm what is that at can
of worms uh cam of worms what the [ __ ]
is going on with this guy
it's a Cameron or my supervisor
seriously just said laksa days ago so
it's lackadaisical lacks my supervisor
seriously just said laksa kadai Zico
oh he's doing it to be funny right laksa
cadiz ago that's like [ __ ] in The
Sopranos when he said genetical you took
his genetical lackadaisical and dude one
of the things I'm most mad at in my life
is I was saying lackadaisical my whole
life and my brother swore to God said by
the way it's laksa days ago and I said
all right I'll start saying laksa days
ago and then I started doing it in years
later my brother was like dude its
lackadaisical kind of [ __ ] [ __ ]
is that what kind of family should is
that and I guarantee doesn't remember it
and he's not gonna eat me like nine
everybody always knew his lackadaisical
[ __ ] that dude that's really shitty to
do to somebody you're not I mean as a
matter of fact I got a I got a [ __ ]
it's got to be this it's got to be this
dude is that lackadaisical or laksa days
ago oh it's like a days it's laksa days
ago really I'll start saying laksa days
ago oh whoops
hey it's laksa days ago oh no really
it's [ __ ] like a days ago but you
told me last days ago no I didn't oh
really
oh dude I can't believe I [ __ ] forgot
to play you guys this dude you were just
chilling that's what's good about this
podcast we're just chill and we're fly
by the seat of our pants and we talk
about whatever the [ __ ] we want to talk
about [ __ ] these podcasts with agendas
dude [ __ ] these podcasts with the
genders
[Music]
when does that like Kermit Wes ha no
like Grover alright dude I'll tell you
what I never played this remember one a
few episodes ago I was talking about my
uncle Vinny how he has two wallets and
[ __ ] like that and then he sent me the
email and then I read the email on the
[ __ ] thing okay so here's the deal I
read the email on the thing I was
calling it Underberg or some [ __ ] he
called me III I don't I didn't know that
he called me and I looked like a day
later and I was like oh [ __ ] he called
me and I checked the message okay now
our iPhone wouldn't have the transcript
available now iPhone get your [ __ ]
together the transcript is never almost
almost never available if you're gonna
have the [ __ ] function have the
function if you're not gonna have the
function don't have the function I don't
want sometimes being able to see the
transcript I want to either see it all
the time or never seriously so this is
what my uncle Vinny caught called me and
left this message and I'm playing it on
the podcast and I told him I was gonna
at least I think I did here we go
and of course and of course here we go
here comes and it's slow and the mangry
my uncle Vinnie scissors II how he's
talking to this is my [ __ ] family you
know well he's a [ __ ] lawyer he puts
on a suit and goes in a courtroom hey
[ __ ] his name's Vinnie it's Italian I
love my family dude
I got a cousin butch - ah that's a
[ __ ] drive-by hey did I have a cousin
butch one time he was like a cuz I had I
guess I don't even remember but when I
was younger I had like I had I had an
attractive cousin like a girl and he was
like I guess it was his daughter and he
was like yeah she's really pretty hot I
was like yeah yeah yeah and he was like
hey you have um you could uh what'd he
say he was like if he wasn't in a family
you could date her huh and I was like
yeah well I don't know yeah and he was
like nah but for real right I was like
yeah sure yeah
like had to do it again and I but for
real yeah sure
I mean come on dude dude you know what's
so [ __ ] up families because you don't
get to choose who the [ __ ] you're with
my love all my family members of this
[ __ ] some of them are crazy some of them
are boring some of them are annoying but
most of them are just like great people
I'm lucky but dude
families are [ __ ] you know you don't
get to do it you don't you don't get to
choose your family
as the wise chanc Smith once said you
don't get to choose your family or
something I don't remember but anyway
that's [ __ ] dude and that crazy that
you just got to be with them and [ __ ]
people don't talk to their families for
years I get it I get it
I [ __ ] for sure get it here's a good
question from from Andre muses at Garcia
gracious cool change it can one can one
ever be revoked aught what is odd of of
okay a spellchecker a proof read can one
ever be revoked of Elder status or are
you set for life once you get it I mean
what are you talking about dude like I
will dude you
can get kicked the [ __ ] out of the log
cabin I mean come on this is a cult
what cult doesn't do drastic things to
keep their their infrastructure the way
it should be dude come on man what am I
gonna just [ __ ] in of course oh you're
an elder and then you murder seven
people you're not an elder anymore
you're an elder and then you walk into a
school and take a [ __ ] on a bunch of
desks while kids are understood you're
not an elder anymore you gotta upkeep
the [ __ ] standards of how we are as
babies oh wow is this that guy that did
the [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah this is the
this guy gets it dude this guy gets it
he's the one with the run after a bouncy
ball how does this guy know dude is this
one of you guys I mean this is so real
this guy gets the vibe man Matthew Heath
coming with it again he was the guy that
did the [ __ ] how [ __ ] is it to run
after a bouncy ball I mean this [ __ ] III
you know what dude Matthew I am proud of
you
@sm Matthew how [ __ ] how [ __ ] it
to climb out the back seat of a two-door
car you know what it's a very [ __ ] but
let me tell you what's even more [ __ ]
Matthew now this is why your vibe is
good but you know what's even more [ __ ]
and I bet if I asked your face-to-face
you'd have the answer it's even more
[ __ ] to climb in the back seat of a
two-door car because you got to like
move the seat belt and like get in and
be like and you're making this noise and
yeah but it's so [ __ ] it's so [ __ ] it
you know what's if you know how [ __ ] it
is to climb out of the back seat of a
two-door car it's as [ __ ] as it is
chasing after a bouncy ball in its own
way I would say the back door one is a
little bit more [ __ ] probably Oh
what is this one fire coming through
with this [ __ ]
Rick Ross having trouble trying to
squeeze into NASCAR race car oh no is
this real does it show it is it's Oh
[ __ ]
oh oh I haven't seen this look we got to
watch Rick Ross having trouble get
trying to squeeze in a NASCAR race car
oh so many pilot car is in that sentence
too much NASCAR race car car car car
oh so [ __ ] Oh first of all that's okay
that's not that [ __ ] yet oh oh using it
to prop up talking to try and make you
know deflect how [ __ ] it is when he
gets that second leg in there that's so
big look a bit cheap look at the picture
how [ __ ] what is that from get in dude
he's not even fat Oh his eyes oh so in
pain wow that was so increasingly [ __ ]
as it went on shut up to all the pears
by the way is he's okay right he had a
he had a [ __ ] heart thing right wow
that's real [ __ ] dude all right well
that's I don't know what I just do
another quit here another question here
and then do we have a most [ __ ] up
Instagram and look at these instagrams
most [ __ ] up Instagram post of the
weeks
here we go looking here you got get
Chuck into the uh-oh selections oh boy
oh man here's one I lost our people Wow
alright here it is just a picture it's a
selfie or a picture from a computer I'm
trying to figure myself out I want to
move with myself hey he can go somewhere
I want to find meaning in my body and in
my mind this existence does not make
this easy perhaps there is a
significance in that I no longer enjoy
the disconnect I noticed between my body
and my mind it makes me feel weak it
causes me to feel lunatic at times and
above reality hmm actually this is kind
of sad maybe I should stop reading it
the end of it though is my love and
attraction
myself strange I feel bad for like the
person's probably under a lot of stress
that's not the most [ __ ] you know what
I didn't announce it I didn't announce
it's the most [ __ ] up Instagram posted
me so it doesn't count you know every
now and then your congratulations we
take a wrong turn and that's fine what
was that last one that was up there I
want to I want to talk about that last
question here dude this is important
okay
people are throwing around the word kuda
and it's not and it's not right Oh CUDA
is not this this person hey what do you
think of people that have a tattoo of
their own name on their body
Kudus no that's not CUDA a CUDA is
somebody who does something blindly
because other people are doing it or
because they see it like and they're
like oh I got to do that oh good that
looks like a good idea our skin I don't
ski but [ __ ] it I'll go look at the snow
that's a CUDA because it comes from
Barracuda who just [ __ ] react off of
shiny objects and attack bracelets and
[ __ ]
that's not CUDA to just get a tattoo of
your name think [ __ ] Simon back strum
with two dots over the [ __ ] vowels in
your which means you're so Swedish Simon
backs from first of all the name backs
from mister Eastern European also is it
the you over the a that what that is
boom wad that's what it's called
oh no that's the two dots oh look at his
face so sweetest suggest woke up at
Simon b3 yeah
but stop throwing this CUDA [ __ ] around
man whatever where there are humans
there are idiots who said that somebody
said that somebody said that on Twitter
the other day actually I should I read
it but I think I'm at about I'm about to
wrap this up dude uh you know some
episodes they're just gonna be [ __ ]
out just under an hour and that's okay
is it but here we go
check out this week's blue apron menu
and get your $30 off at blue apron comm
/ Congrats square cash have you switched
yet
download the free square cash app and
two rewards code Congrats get five
dollars give five dollars - times up get
it for iOS or Android now and here's the
other thing - I've got some dates coming
up I announced the second leg of the the
congratulate had to follow the leader
tour and it's selling out so let's get
let's get on that Pittsburgh
I think it's sold out Dayton I don't
know if that I don't know
Huntsville Nashville is sold out maybe
Denver and Boise sold out I added late
shows the second leg Eugene Oregon
Sacramento is sold out Red Bank New
Jersey might be sold out Wilmington
Redding Pennsylvania Tulsa Midwest
Dallas Portland Maine so it's Portland
Maine not Portland Oregon but I will be
coming to Portland Oregon on the third
leg so oh wait Hampton Beach
Mashantucket Houston Wichita Kansas City
Lincoln Reno Las Vegas subscribe to our
YouTube channel
download the Krista Lea app for iOS or
Android and also you can see this
podcast before anybody else that's
before a real baby video episodes go up
Tuesdays or Wednesdays watch my special
and I'm shooting more episodes of that
show alone together which I love very
much so check that out
thank you for listening and you guys
[Music]